I don't think many people are familiar with the idea
that boredom can be stressful.
Can you talk a little bit about that?
Yeah.
Since so many kids are bored.
Yes, and it's certainly profoundly seen on the behavior
when students were asked why they're dropping out of high school.
The number one response was boredom.
And when they were asked to break it down-- what do you mean, boredom?
It would be, the subject wasn't interesting.
Or it would be, the information wasn't relevant to me.
So boredom is certainly a problem in terms of what happened, the outcome.
But with boredom and repetition, it is very much like the confinement and lack
of choice that stresses animals put in cages or people put in prisons
or confined against their will.
The brain is a searching, surviving structure that
is out to explore and make sense of the world
and to be able to respond to input, and when there's lack of choice,
that sense of confinement is frightening, it's threatening,
and it threatens the sense of survival.
So the brain goes on high alert.
The stress goes up.
The lower brain gets to be in charge.
And as I said, the neural networks conducting-- with neuroplasticity,
it gets more and more efficient wiring of the system into the lower brain
and disconnect from the upper brain.
Boredom reflects a global judgment that you
don't think there's information to be gleaned from the environment,
so it's better to ramp down the energy you're expending.
But what's really interesting is the act of being
bored itself creates stress on the brain because your brain doesn't
want to be bored.
It's seeking out information.
And so that stress is going to compel you
to act to try to solve that problem, which in a classroom
usually looks like disruption or other kinds of things.
So we have this really terrible place we're
in when you design on average-- you create situations
where kids that fall behind get stressed from that, which
then impairs their ability to learn.
But the kids that could keep moving are fine, are actually held back,
and they're bored, which creates stress, which has an impairment on learning.
So you've got these environments that are really serving nobody.